i can put a stand in because i won't  hold things this shape anymore  i know who i am  i know my strengths  because she's a  she's a lesbian i don't know did you get  it did you get the joke there  it's the no no no no hold on listen  listen just to test up did you get it i  don't think you got it it's she's a  lesbian  so  she only mentions it 19 times per minute  when she's on stage so you might you  might not have picked up on it lesbians  lesbians lesbians lesbian lesbians  but uh yeah she is a lesbian that's the  joke there some people think it's  strange that i would take the pill  as a as a lesbian a spoiler alert  hey did you  wait i just need to stop it there for a  second because it this is breaking news  okay  hannah gadsby  is a lesbian  wow  wow i know your disappointment's  palpable mate